hey if you haven't already got it get
yourself a copy of answer the Internet
the card game it's available right now
in the link in the bio or you can get a
bar salal Mart Amazon or Spencer Gifts
play along with us let's get it what's
up I'm Chris D'Elia
and I'm here to answer the internet
let's do this if you had to go to Mars
for ten years with Trump and Kim K but
when you get back you get the combined a
net worth of both of them could you do
it ten years well I'd be 50 when I came
back that's a lot of money is yeah I
know Kim K has a shitload of money Trump
has a honestly that sounds like
something that I would do for and I will
I will tell you this I wouldn't even
want to for the sheer entertainment
value go to dinner with the two of them
for two I know people who would be like
oh yeah but wouldn't you want to sit
down and even if you could what a chant
don't know no [ __ ] chance no no oh
but that's what do you call it a but
[ __ ] experience with something Jesus
crisis point he's crazy I don't need
that [ __ ] experience and and you know
what dude
that's a lot of money but what I don't
more money more problems I don't need
the money I'm fine
I you know that money of course we do a
lot with it but my life's fine I got a
car got a house I'm happy enough I don't
need to be a Mars for [ __ ] ten years
no no way if you came back you could
probably develop a pretty sick series or
maybe have a lot of stand-up to do with
it imagine I went to Mars for tenure and
then came back and [ __ ] created a TV
show
oh no way I would come back in ten years
permanently with this face what happened
to your butt you aged poorly and I would
be like I was on Mars for [ __ ] 10
years with Trump and Kim K there was a
combined total of four and a half hours
I didn't have this face would you rather
you and all your friends be mall cops at
the same mall or substitute teachers at
the same high school dude oh man
the mall a hundred percent first of all
let me go and let me say that III didn't
like school and I also think that malls
are the most exhausting places in the
world like have you ever gone shopping
for an hour and a half in a public like
that's like working out for three hours
it's like three hours hard doing hit
HIIT like that's really yeah I I never
want to be near a sales do you know what
I mean
ever want to be here I never want to be
near an Orange Julius I don't work in
mall Santa that's for sure but I will
tell you what I do want what I do want
to do at the mall is have [ __ ]
Authority is then you can go to brats
you can be like you know what sales this
is what's up aren't Julius this is
what's up and moretta this is what's up
and this is how we're doing it a hundred
percent and with my friends that's
awesome dude I have the number one
called in all of them also like um all
malls [ __ ] suck to the mall
you're 2020 you're out of your [ __ ]
minds or the [ __ ] online you really
don't like mom if you're 16 a malls fine
because you get them all in your leg
this is me get that's your like that's
your that was for me I didn't I never
smoked weed or drank I was for me like
my bad boy [ __ ] I like let's go to the
Glendale Galleria but man [ __ ] all these
kiosks also there's the other thing if
the stores in a mall that's it
the fact that there's also kiosks is
[ __ ] [ __ ] don't a store outside
where there's no store I am [ __ ]
Israeli like here put this on put this
on your back put it on your back I'm
outside of the store
do you feel like you kind of have a
little bit of this vibe with like you
and all your friends being stand-up
comics and podcasters what vibe just
like you know you it's maybe it's not
mall cop or substitute teachers but you
have this network of guys where all you
see each other at the club you know
they're all each other's shows all that
country yeah that's basically what it is
I mean we at the Comedy Store we are
[ __ ] mall cops we are good no cuz
seriously I'll be there and like you
know either Rogen or Whitney Cummings
will come up to me and be like hey watch
out for this [ __ ] guy and I'll be
like all the tanks that will walk the
other hood means we're more in each
other right would you rather die right
now or live on another one for our than
you 1,000 years a hundred percent I
don't like what people are like dude it
maybe it's I've always felt this
pretentious when people are like oh but
who would want to live forever cuz then
you see all your friends die [ __ ] that
dude I can't wait to see my friends die
dude if you don't hate your friends you
ain't [ __ ] and I've said this for so
long if you think your friends aren't
annoying and you don't want to strangle
them every now and then then you're not
a real person
dude I would I as a matter of fact take
out the would you rather die right now
you could just be like do you want to
live in other thousand years my answer
would be like yeah so I can see my
friends die Bryan Callen you're gonna
[ __ ] bury him and just laugh thousand
years for Bryan Callen to die ain't gonn
what do you know there's six years for
Bryan Callen
what is the weirdest thing you could
find on your buddy's laptop uh probably
like [ __ ] man I don't
so it's it's weird oh it's it's tough
too weird a comedian out because I mean
we it's like I have friends that text me
like awful [ __ ] like I don't want to
expose like I have other comedian
friends that text me [ __ ] where I'm like
ah [ __ ] come on I mean some guy the
video of another guy [ __ ] putting a
yeah a golf ball and at the end of
camera tracks a golf ball and there's a
dude with his legs spread open and the
golf ball goes up a ramp into his
[ __ ] [ __ ] Bryn's texting me that
then there's nothing weird on anybody's
laptop to me the sound that ball makes
when it goes in the company's a Sun
believable you've seen it by the way
that friend is who I want to see die in
the next time if there was a mating
season where you get to [ __ ] for three
weeks and the rest of the year you don't
deal with the opposite sex would you be
more productive at work one time when I
was a kid oh I was in college and I said
and I was talking to my friend Ted and I
was saying to him man doesn't it suck
that girl girls don't want to have sex
with guys as much as guys when I have
sex with girls and he said no and I said
why and he said because girls have to
not want to have sex a lot of the time
because if not then [ __ ] wouldn't get
done everyone the whole world there
would be like no inventions we don't
know where we'd be what everyone would
you be [ __ ] all the time and I was
like that's a really good point you know
here's the thing if there was a mating
season where you get to [ __ ] for three
weeks and the rest of the 49 weeks
you couldn't [ __ ] nobody could [ __ ] I
feel like probably this pandemic would
have wrapped up in about a week and a
half
rotavirus would have been like alright
[ __ ] it and then die because there's no
way that that's a I mean even though
because the world's most elite
scientists never got [ __ ]
on you till they be world's most elite
sizes that's why they became the world's
most elite scientists is because they
couldn't get laid
they'd be like you want to hang out and
they'd go by that [ __ ] no you want to
hang out [ __ ] no and be like all right I
guess gotta make this vaccine right yeah
now that they're that guy they're
getting [ __ ]
so we need the guys just under that just
under that that are coming up that are
still like I wish I could get my dick
wet you know what I mean yeah if the
boat is the great motivator exists it's
the reason why people get out of bed in
the morning they won't admit it but
that's why there you go man you need get
create this vaccine so you can get some
[ __ ] basically as once they put that on
my tombstone if you could have all the
powers of Harry Potter but you could
only have sex with inanimate objects
would you do it ah that's a good one
Harry Potter book II know uh man that's
a good one [ __ ] it I think I'd do it man
I think I would do it man uh but you
would get that's that by the way nobody
gets more [ __ ] than a wizard Tom thing
cuz it's like you know the whole thing
about Harry Potter is is like he's new
Noble he doesn't use his you know power
for evil if I was a wizard with Harry
Potter's uh power I would be an evil
evil evil wizard like other Wizards
would be like that guy would be like I
don't know I can't roll with I can't
roll with no I I would do some good but
I would also do mostly bad but also be
[ __ ] all sorts of inanimate objects
[ __ ] it I don't give a [ __ ] and people
will be like oh that guy's [ __ ] a
bicycle and I will be like here we go
would you watch the UFC where little
kids are beating the [ __ ] out of each
other oh [ __ ]
there's one hand where you're like well
big well little kids can't really hurt
each other
that hard but you think about how their
bodies are littler so maybe that pain is
more amplified would I watch it no I
wouldn't watch it dude I don't even
watch the bum fights man when people
send me like links to [ __ ] like that I
say what's in this I saw I saw a bear a
video of a bear and I was like oh that's
no it was a video of a deer and I was
like oh that's so cute and then all of a
sudden a bear rushed
into the backyard and sank his teeth
into this and like I understand for a
guy like me there's only before and
after that video like there's no like
I'm I'm different now you understand so
I even watched the thing where who's the
guy who understands silverware huh Oh as
soon as I saw that comment I went nope I
don't watch it I don't want I can't
watch that I can't watch it so kids
fighting each other would probably be
among those things yeah
would you rather find a million dollars
but it's mob money oh I already think
that that's yes and you have a 20
percent chance of getting killed by the
mob or [ __ ] the girl of your dreams
but you have an 80% chance of getting an
STD well and I don't know quite how rich
you are so if a million dollars doesn't
move the needle up I got it yeah I was
taking you know if I was one of you I
would say I'd rather here's the thing
I'd rather get the mob money and let me
tell you why I need some interesting
[ __ ] like that in my life I mean I I
don't even look at the million dollars
of mob money the money isn't even the
thing the fact that I could have some
[ __ ] where I got to look over my
shoulder that's awesome to me it makes
me it makes me like it makes you so sexy
it makes you so sexy if you think well
you never know what could happen I could
be [ __ ] killed today right that's
awesome and I like me in sexy and I feel
like I'm rich I'm richer with the mob
money and I'm sexier and there's an 80%
chance I'll be okay I would take those
odds I would take those odds and I'd
spend money and just be sexy as [ __ ]
great stuff dude thanks so much those
money